so here's the scene that I was
incredibly proud of as a director but
you know just didn't work inside of the
side of the confines of our of our film
this is scene between the characters a
Quay in a copy and I'm in are making the
scene was the attention for the
audience's to really realize that that
equation what cog we're husband and wife
um so I had it kind of had a
confrontation like argument about where
where Connor was gonna go after the
child's death you know in the in the in
the in the tribal council room I was it
was a scene with the incredible
performers just from from from Danai
gurira and uh Daniel Kuya but it just
didn't working it in the film but I'm
really excited for folks that folks to
see it anyway you didn't seem to have a
problem when he was thrown from the
force he was the King's challenged he
lost he was not fit to lead the Chara
taught me to my face right here if you
bring back did he do it he had him did
jakka stole him from Alec I don't care
crossed off from us he murdered my
mother and father thirty years there's
been no justice and teach others were to
bring him back not taken to the UN not
taken to the CIA but bring him here to
us
this is what you would have me leave the
door of all to bring our children into
this world where they become conquerors
yes that children will be leaders of a
truly free world not just a tiny country
where we have to hide everything that
makes us great euro in war
but in the end it will be beautiful and
Wakanda will stand tall
you
you